[Musique]
vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir les Assises
nationales au Burkina Faso pour désigner
un président de transition deux semaines
après un deuxième en 8 mois qui a
vu porter au pouvoir le capitaine
Ibrahim Traoré c'est partisans
souhaiterait le voir endosser ce rôle
nous ferons un point de cette première
journée dès le début de ce journal
la polémique qui en Afrique du Sud
concernant le sort de 200000
ressortissants de Zimbabwe il pourrait
bientôt être forcé de quitter le pays
pour cause d'expiration de titres de
séjour reportage à suivre dans cette
édition
plus qu'une star nous recevons une icône
mondiale de la musique née au Bénin
c'est une chanteuse à la voix puissante
et à l'énergie communicative le tout
servi par un engagement permanent auprès
de la jeunesse mondiale et africaine en
particulier Angelique Kidjo et l'invité
du journal de l'Afrique avec une
actualité chargée à un concert
exceptionnel à la fine harmonie ce
samedi et un nouvel album avec Ibrahim
Maalouf
ils étaient des centaines de délégués
réunis ce vendredi pour le début des
Assises nationales au Burkina Faso
objectif désigner le nouveau président
de la transition mais au centre des
regards l'absent de ces assises le
capitaine Ibrahim Traoré auteur du coup
d'État du 30 septembre dernier et
favoris pour le poste notre
correspondant vangali Touré y était
voici son récit
quelques 300 délégués étaient présents
ce matin dans cette salle de conférence
de Ouaga à 2000 pour l'ouverture de ces
Assises nationales à noter que le
capitaine Ibrahima Traoré n'était pas
présent il s'est fait représenter par le
capitaine Méda qui a lu un discours à
son nom un discours dans lequel il a
insisté sur l'unité des Burkinabè en
cette période de crise politique et
sécuritaire à noter également la
présence de quelques têtes d'affiche de
paysages politiques et de la société et
civile au burkinabè qui nous ont exprimé
leur aspiration pour ses assises nous
espérons que les uns et les autres vont
transcendent leurs intérêts égoïssistes
et regarder plutôt l'intérêt général la
nation c'est de travailler à ce que nous
maintient les groupes armées terroristes
et permettre le retour des personnes
déplacées internes dans leur localités
et je suis là également pour plaider
pour prise en compte des questions liées
aux personnes vivant attaquer handicap
parce que comme vous le savez nous les
personnes handicapées nous avons des
besoins spécifiques qu'il faut tenir
compte nous avons pu constater la
présence des manifestants aux alentours
de ce palais de conférence de Ouaga à
2000 arborant les drapeaux russes et
burkinabè ces assises doivent aboutir à
l'adoption de la Charte de la transition
mais surtout la désignation du président
de la transition qui doit mener le pays
vers les prochaines élections il
semblerait que la majorité des délégués
a déjà choisi le président capitaine
Ibrahima Traoré
l'instabilité du Burkina Faso plongez
vous le savez dans une crise politique
aiguë depuis plusieurs mois inquiète
au-delà de ses frontières et en
particulier chez les voisins Ivoiriens
le pays compte en effet plus de 3
millions de burkinabés dont 60% sont nés
en Côte d'Ivoire donc correspondance
sont allés à leur rencontre reportage
Soumaïla et Issiaka d'origine burkinabe
son nez et en grandit en Côte d'Ivoire
depuis le coup d'État qui a frappé le
Burkina Faso le 30 septembre il se
retrouve régulièrement entre
compatriotes pour parler de crise
politique tous s'inquiètent pour leurs
proches au pays grâce à ça concerne deux
armées au sein d'un même pays bon ça
fait peur ça inquiète parce que on sait
pas comme le djihadisme prend de
l'emprunt on sait pas au fur et à mesure
si demain on peut apprendre qui suit
s'approche de la famille là-bas donc
c'est c'est inquiétant surtout c'est le
deuxième beaucoup d'États au Burkina
Faso en moins d'un an pour le président
du Conseil national du burkinabè de Côte
d'Ivoire la plus grande association
burkinabè du pays leur n'est pas à la
division mais à la mobilisation
le tourisme parce qu'il faut que tous on
s'émer ensemble soit
ivoirien soit burkinabé soit malienne
soit nigérienne
qui peut nous aider en 2020 moins de 3%
des importations ivoiriennes provenaient
du Burkina Faso et seulement 8% des
exportations aller vers Ouagadougou mais
ces chiffres ne prennent pas en compte
le secteur informel selon cette
économiste à long terme l'instabilité du
Burkina Faso pourrait avoir des
conséquences sur les relations
bilatérales l'augmentation effectivement
de l'insécurité peut effectivement agir
sur
la perception sur le risque et s'il y a
l'insécurité grandit les investisseurs
donc ivoirien spécifiquement peuvent
quitter effectivement le Burkina et ça
peut avoir un impact significatif sur
l'économie burkinabé la Côte d'Ivoire
compte plus de 3 millions de Burkinabè
sur son territoire un chiffre qui
pourrait augmenter vu la situation en
2022 ce sont près de 7000 réfugiés
burkinabè qui ont traversé la frontière
pour fuir les attaques djihadistes
on passe à l'actualité au Tchad après la
nomination du Premier ministre salé
katzabo le président Mahamad Idriss Abi
Itno a fait connaître ce vendredi la
composition du gouvernement composé de
44 membres avec 22 nouveaux ministres
parmi lesquels l'ancien rebelle Tom RDV
et le diplomate mahammat salé à natif
l'autre actualité du jour c'est cette
polémique qui fait rage en Afrique du
Sud concernant les Zimbabwe ils sont
plus de 200 000 qui pourraient être
forcés à quitter le pays à cause de
l'expiration de leur titre de séjour une
solution rentrée chez eux et faire leur
demande depuis arrêt impossible pour la
plupart des immigrés les organisations
de la société civile y voilà une mesure
xénophobe reportage de notre
correspondante Caroline Dumay avec
Nadine Theron et Stéphane Carson
là qui est arrivé en Afrique du Sud en
2008 il avait un travail stable pendant
14 ans jusqu'à ce que l'entreprise qui
l'employait découvre que son visa allait
expirer les permis de travail de tous
les Zimbabwe ne seront plus renouvelés
ils devront rentrer au pays
il n'y a rien c'est difficile c'est pour
ça qu'on est venu ici au départ on était
des réfugiés économiques
là qui sait qu'il ne pourra pas rester
en Afrique du Sud au-delà de juin 2023
est-il devra redemander un permis à
partir du Zimbabwe une procédure chère
qui a peu de chances d'aboutir c'est
pour contester cette nouvelle
réglementation que cette fondation a
décidé d'attaquer le gouvernement
justice sa directrice déplore que les
Zimbabwe n'est même pas été consultés
les lois sud-africaines depuis plus de
10 ans il faut quand même qu'il soit
entendu il faut leur laisser la chance
de participer au processus qui les
concerne
le gouvernement sud-africain est en
train d'adopter une série de lois pour
limiter l'immigration sous la pression
de l'opinion publique qui voit d'un très
mauvais œil la présence de près de 5
millions d'immigrés dans un pays où le
chômage ne fait que croître
mais ça ne devrait pas être comme
l'autre pandémie qui est incontrôlable
si on en est là c'est parce que certains
n'ont pas fait leur boulot
si le procès contre le gouvernement qui
commencera en décembre naboutit pas plus
de 200000 Zimbabwe vont devoir faire
leurs valises
allez on passe à la culture dans ce
journal
notre invité de ce soir est né à Ouidah
au Bénin et à l'instar des guerrières
Amazon du Dahomey c'est une source
d'inspiration intarissable une icône
mondiale de la musique qui n'a de cesse
de se renouveler autant en genre et en
collaboration et sa musique ne laisse
personne indifférent écouter plutôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ma tête
[Musique]
différentes et à la maison nos parents
toujours encourager cette différence
d'opinion toujours encourager le fait
que des gens du monde entier pour venir
à la maison parler des langues qu'on
comprenait pas je me suis jamais
annuelle à la maison donc du coup je ne
vois pas pourquoi je m'amener dans en
faisant la chanson la musique m'a amené
à découvrir des endroits où j'ai jamais
mis les pieds à travers les musiques je
connais déjà l'Amérique avant de mettre
les pieds en Amérique ah à travers la
musique j'ai connu l'Afrique dans le
sens plus large du terme sans jamais la
famille les pieds en République
démocratique du Congo après j'ai été
c'est-à-dire que la musique pour moi
c'est la porte sur le reste du monde et
le monde est multiple beau mais c'est ah
c'est trop beau mais en tout cas vous
nous influez ça à travers votre musique
et alors votre actualité immédiate c'est
ce concert exceptionnel donc samedi ce
samedi 14 octobre donc à la Philharmonie
il s'agit de rendre hommage à fait la
couture l'autre légende du continent
africain décédé qui vient évidemment du
Nigéria et alors vous allez reprendre
donc de Talking head dont on sait peu
finalement que ils sont déjà inspirés à
la base de félins c'était ça l'idée au
départ mais c'était ça l'idée en fait
quand je suis arrivée en France à 83
j'ai attendu je suis une cassette la
chanson One signal like time sans savoir
qui c'était et cette chanson m'a suivi
en fait parce que quand on vient d'une
dictature toutes ses musiques là ne sont
pas non pas ils sont pas arrivés chez
vous et c'est comme une retournée à
l'africaine donc rester et un jour j'ai
commencé à me dire il faut que je
reprenne cette chanson et je m'entends
dire par mon mon manager mon mari mais
c'est le talking moi je connais David
j'ai jamais fait le lien je me dis je
vais écouter tout l'album et j'aime
regarder tu es sûr de ça cet album est
absurde il y a pas de parole les paroles
on comprendrait je dis ah moi j'ai été
pas des personnes âgées les proverbes en
Afrique on mange ça tous les jours
mettez-moi la musique et dès la de la
première chanson je me suis dit je
reprends tout l'album morceau par
morceau mais elle a ramena à l'Afrique
par le le la musique de départ qui les
influencé fais la Coutu absolument alors
c'est du coup la boucle est bouclée moi
j'ai dit toujours toutes les musiques
viennent d'Afrique et je le rame je
ramène toujours toutes les musiques en
Afrique il y a des gens qui sont contre
ça quand je dis ça ils sont pas contents
j'ai dit pour rejeter votre humanité
c'est bon ne me soyez pas d'Afrique
alors soyez vous venez mais tout le
monde est africain parce que nous sommes
des homosapiens et dans notre ADN
l'Afrique est présent tout le temps tous
les jours absolument et alors l'autre
actualité que vous avez parce que avec
vous vous êtes tellement vous êtes
tellement d'énergie il faut vous suivre
pour pouvoir vous suivre alors c'est cet
album avec le trompettiste libanov
français donc Ibrahim Maalouf je propose
qu'on écoute un extrait justement et on
en parle juste après
on n'a pas d'extrait c'est dommage parce
que j'aurais voulu qu'on entende Queen
Saba justement alors par le parlez-nous
de justement de cette collaboration là
mais quand on a décidé de travailler
ensemble le mot but à moi et la question
que je posais à Ibrahim à ce moment là
c'est quel est le lien de l'Afrique et
le Moyen-Orient
moi j'aime toujours l'histoire ramener
l'histoire de l'humanité dans mon
travail et j'ai fait des recherches je
me suis rendu compte que c'est un semis
de la reine Saba est dans la Bible le
Coran la Torah dans toutes les religions
elle est racontée et même on est juste
au Nigéria elle appelait différents noms
je me suis dit ah ça c'est intéressant
j'ai commencé à faire des recherches sur
les énigmes qu'elle posait au roi
Salomon qui était selon le dire le roi
la personne la plus sage du monde ah
j'ai dit ah ça m'intéresse une femme qui
va demander à un homme tu es sage
montre-moi comment tu es sage je vais te
montrer te poser des énigmes et les
énigmes que j'ai choisi sont absolument
intéressantes parce que ça parle
justement des problèmes auxquels nous
faisons face le droit des femmes la
chanson ENI c'est ça
quel est le le
quelle est la le truc la chose qui sort
qui n'a pas de plume qui n'a pas de sang
c'est le poussin qui sort de l'oeuvre la
femme au milieu 9 mois 7 jours un enfant
ouais
alors là c'est je pense que les le
public va être intéressant de voir
d'autres énigmes les énigmes il faut
d'autres épines
moi je donne je donne ces deux là comme
ça mais il faut pas lire la réponse il
faut écouter la chanson il faut écouter
et se demander ce que ça ça et lire
aussi le texte qui oblige à réfléchir et
oblige à réfléchir une une femme qui est
au pouvoir en Afrique noir qui va voir
le roi Salomon pour lui dire si tu es
vraiment sage j'ai besoin de ta Savage
ça c'est sagesse pour gouverner mon
peuple on le fait plus ça aujourd'hui
est-ce que nos dirigeants sont ont de la
sagesse c'est actuel aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on s'écoute est-ce qu'on a on est-ce
qu'on peut dépasser le clivage et penser
et mettre au centre de nos
préoccupations je dis je passe surtout
des hommes politiques le bien-être des
populations c'est ça la question
aujourd'hui c'est que ça c'est pas
possible en ce moment c'est possible
mais on a on a on a fait beaucoup
d'erreurs en route est-ce que il y aura
un dirigeant qui sera suffisamment sage
et humble pour dire on a des erreurs
recommençons à zéro c'est top cet homme
ou cette femme qui dira ça et bien moi
je vais aller je vais aller travailler
avec Direct oui on peut il est pas exclu
d'espérer et alors
c'est ce qu'on dit absolument alors en
attendant au-delà de la figure de la
reine de Saba il y a aussi le film que
porte va il a Davis donc de womanking où
voilà elles ont réhabilité ces fameuses
guerrières de Dahomey et qu'est-ce que
ça vous fait justement vous vous êtes
originaire de là-bas du Bénin qu'est-ce
que ça vous fait justement que ces
figures là féminines fortes africaines
soit pour une fois j'allais dire en tout
cas mise au devant de la scène comme ça
ben il était temps mais il y a beaucoup
d'histoires qu'on doit raconter en
Afrique beaucoup de d'histoire de femmes
d'hommes
vaillant et valent c'est à dire que
notre histoire nous a été prise parce
que nous ont réduit un esclavage et qui
ont nous ont colonisé
et nous sommes toujours dans cette
attitude d'attendre que les autres
parlent à notre nom moi
je raconte ma propre histoire ne parle
pas pour moi nous avons des têtes de
chez nous nous avons des historiens chez
nous nous avons des gens fantastiques en
Afrique il serait temps qu'on commence à
prendre à nos enfants nos propres
histoires avant de leur apprendre
l'histoire des États-Unis du reste du
monde nous d'abord on doit comprendre
notre histoire et à la connaître pour
que quand l'esclavage commence
recommencera parce que l'histoire est un
éternelle recommencement qu'on sache ce
qui se présente et qu'on se battent
contre l'esclavage et contre la
colonisation parce que les gens jouent
aujourd'hui les gens sont en colère les
jeunes sont en collants en Afrique mais
ils ont pas suffisamment d'éducation ne
pas suffisamment des formations pour
être fort et être fier de leur propre
histoire et dire mais non moi je ne suis
pas réduit à ma pauvreté je suis
quelqu'un qui vient d'une culture riche
il faut qu'on soit on le raconte ses
histoires là il est absolument
indispensable que les cinéastes les
comptes les écrivent tous autant que
nous sommes nous nous mettons servis de
nos histoires et qu'on les raconte
absolument c'est très important et
l'autre Pange puis dire si je devais en
choisir qu'un dans votre carrière et
dans votre dévouement c'est aussi votre
engagement auprès des de la jeunesse et
en particulier c'est dans la droite
ligne de ce qu'on disait des jeunes
filles vous êtes ambassadrice pour
l'UNICEF vous avez votre fondation donc
c'est très important pour vous cet
engagement et on sait qu'il vous tient à
cœur mais ça me tient à cœur parce que
je me rends compte au jour d'aujourd'hui
ça fait longtemps que je m'en suis rendu
compte mais plus que jamais maintenant
surtout après la pandémie si les femmes
sont centre de tout partout pas
seulement à l'Afrique en particulier les
femmes africaines sont la colonne sont
les colonnes vertébrale de l'Afrique
sans les femmes l'Afrique s'écroule et
on passe notre temps à écouter les
hommes qui nous parlent des femmes et
qui veulent réduire la femme à un objet
un objet de désir un objet à une
serviette à une serpillière mais rien
Pâques à un être humain les hommes
africains les hommes en général n'a
jamais s'il y a pas de femme il y a pas
d'homme sans femme ce n'est pas un homme
qui donne naissance à un homme et à une
femme il faut deux personnes donc
l'homme est forcé d'être le partenaire
de la femme et la femme est aussi force
d'être partenaire de l'homme un homme ne
peut pas se dire fier de cette petite
fille de sa mère de ses sœurs de sa
tante de ses femmes s'il n'a pas le
respect pour la femme le reste pour la
femme on doit l'inculquer à nos ans à
nos enfants nous les femmes africaines
nous devons élever nos petits garçons en
leur faisant dire en leur savoir leur
petite sœur n'est pas le bobonne le
petit swag d'être respecté leur petite
sœur aussi une voix à la maison laissée
parler les petites filles à la maison et
les petits garçons et arrêtons de dire
que les enfants n'ont pas de voix
absolument ce message personnel je le
prends pour moi aussi merci infiniment
j'ai liquidjo d'être venu et c'est ainsi
que nous referme ce journal de l'Afrique
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivi et
en particulier tient de wida à Paris en
passant par Los Angeles partout où vous
soyez restez avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur France 24
[Musique]